Okay. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich this is radio lab
and today we still desperately looking,
seeking symmetry as you say, oh, not
well yet. We have looked at love, failed,
looked at brain veiled mirrors, failed
chemistry of light, so we thought,
well for the last stop on this trip,
if we were to go anywhere to
find or look for deep unity,
a deep oneness and symmetry, maybe the
beginning of everything moment zero,
we found ourselves a physicist.
I get, it's Neil degrasse Tyson.
I began with a very, very basic question.
If you look at me and I look at you and
you seem to be made of stuff and I seem
to be made of stuff and here we
are on here are tables and chairs.
Is it surprised you in some deep way
that we are all here made of stuff?
Yes. It's, it's not so much surprise
understates it. It's shocking.
Really Shocking, Huh? What is,
what is shocking that there's any
matter in the universe at all?
Meaning that this conversation
shouldn't be happening deeper mouth
deeper than just whether or not
we'd be having this conversation.
It's whether or not any of this would
exist. Earth, the galaxy and the like.
Whew.
Okay. So, um, if you go
back 13.7 billion years ago,
that's my shoulder Gliser again,
the physicist and he says,
if you rolled back the history
of the universe, no more stars,
no molecules, no atoms can
play the movie backwards. Now,
all the way to the beginning,
just after you know,
[inaudible]
Bang, you have what we
call a primeval soup.
This soup was actually, it was
made of light, universal of white,
very high energy. And out of this
energy does heat these interactions,
you suddenly get
that these are belches, Jad belts,
belches of matter. The
light is doing this. Yes,
this is the one that equals MC squared
is all about cause energy is just a form
of matter and vice versa. I feel like I
should know what you're talking about,
but I don't. Okay, let's, let's
start. Let's start a little simpler.
There's light all around us. We're
in a studio. It's visible light.
So this light has no mass has energy.
Even o m [inaudible] crank up the
energy of the light. Go to ultra violet
x-rays,
and there's a point in x-rays where
you have a high enough x-ray photon,
it will spontaneously
turn into a particle
electrons. In fact. Oh,
so you're saying if you crank up the
e the energy of the light high enough,
it'll suddenly just turn into mass.
That's correct. So just picture the soup
really intensely hot,
and it's belching out now to do
electrons Zumi around [inaudible]
forks, neutrinos continuously churning,
churning, churning. Over time,
all that matter clumps together in more
and more complex forms until you finally
get us. Sounds. Maybe
simple, doesn't it? Chat?
Yes, but there's a but coming, I can
smell it. But, and here's the big knew.
Back in 1928 1929 there
was this physicist,
young guy called IRAC.
He's doing some math and he's thinking
about this whole business of turning
light into matter. Okay? Now
he's puzzled by something.
But there is a law in physics called
the law of conservation of charge,
which simply means this, my unit rolls
off your tongue quite nicely, doesn't it?
It does. So here's what it means.
Whenever you create something,
if it you beginning,
you have zero electric charge at the end
you have to have zero electric charge
to that is you cannot create electric
charge. You have to keep the balance,
make something in the universe that has
a positive charge or a neck like make an
electron. Okay, just
make one right now. Yeah,
gone. That electron has a, you remember,
remember this from eighth grade,
a negative negative one bay
make, make two electrons.
Now make three electrons negative three.
Now if the universe is to stay in balance,
you need to have something
that has a positive charge.
You've got three minuses on one side
and you have nothing else. Second,
if this is true, how would
you even make an electron?
The sheer fact of creating an electron
puts it out of balance. Well here,
here's the middle story here. Well, no,
Paul, Dereck, that well, how about this?
What if every time you
created an electron,
you created an entire electron?
What every particle could have an
equal but opposite in tight particle.
That is a particle that
looks very much the same,
but essentially it's
electric charge is reversed.
It would look the same.
Like really look, yes.
You'd have to measure their properties
to know that they were different.
Is it a mirror image or am I
think of it as a mirror image.
There's a thing called quantum spin and
it would just be spinning the opposite
way, but charge as the most
obvious difference. For example,
the anti-matter cousin of the electron
because the electron is a negative
charge. This little guy should
have a positive charge. Exactly.
But in every other way it'd be the
same. Right. And no one ever seen one.
He just thought that there
probably would be one. Yes.
And why did he think
this? Math, math, math.
It was a solution to the his equations.
And that's the beauty of theoretical
physics. I solve equations.
You can sometimes find out about the
world. And then yes, a few years later
bought a bing, they found the positron,
the anti-matter version of the electron.
Oh yeah. No, it's deep. It's
deep. How did they do that?
Like [inaudible] see it?
Well particles. Um, you know,
they're very tiny, right?
You can't really see them.
So all you do is uh, you,
you create little systems in the,
you get like a vapor and you put
the vapor in a tank, he says,
and when the electron or the Ante
Electron shoots through the vapor,
the particle destabilizes the vapor
and makes little bubbles. Okay.
You can see these little bubbles
appearing out of [inaudible] series.
Really an amazing thing. So you
can't see the particle itself,
but you can see its shadow. It's
road trip. It's road trip. Yeah.
So then he says, okay,
imagine you get this little piece of
light and heat it up really hot so that it
spawns all as we've learned, not one
particle but two matter anti-matter pair,
but them in the a vapor tank
and you put a magnet in there,
you can tell if it's going to the left
or to the right if it's a positive or
negative charge. [inaudible]
cooler. It is cool.
You see two particle tracks that each
curl opposite directions and if they have
the same rate of curl, yeah, that
means they have the same mass
[inaudible].
So if we go back to our picture of
the early universe of the soup, which,
and you named all of those particles,
does that mean that for every
particle that you named there is,
it's opposite floating around there as
well. Exactly. Do you have electrons?
Anti electrons.
You try and answer a neutron Proton
Anti-proton this is all very beautiful.
And you'd say, great, I have a
very democratic universe, you know,
has many particles and
antiparticles and everybody's happy.
All your problem is the following.
When an electron and a positron meet,
they will find each other and uh oh
quite a bit.
And they will annihilate you winning.
They'll find it because they'll find
their original other hand. No, no.
They wouldn't need to know. Just find
another kind like that's correct.
That's correct. So Chad, now imagine
that we're in the very early universe.
I am a teeny bit of matter. And you
may be opposite. I'm an anti cro,
which anti-coal anticoag.
And so the program,
which is sitting here and I see you
across the, he's now I'm positive.
Charge your name. We
charge charges together.
[inaudible]
you see, it doesn't work out too well
for us. But you know, hey, wait, wait.
This is actually a rather profound puzzle
because if Paul Dirac was right and
half the universe is matter,
the other half of the university's Andy
mattered and we all bumped into each
other, the less we just did. Well
eventually I guess we would just not,
we would just become, I don't what, Oh,
I don't know. Hmm. We would not
be here. Damn. Just blink out.
And there'd be nothing. Exactly.
Really nothing. Nothing on there.
So it's a field of view,
mostly not mostly just
radiation, radiation,
radiation, radiation, radiation,
radiation, radiation, radiation.
Shocking.
[inaudible]
well,
there's something wrong with this theory
because we're talking to each other.
So something, something's
wrong with this notion. Yes.
And what's wrong is an imperfection in
the laws of physics that we know of now,
and that, uh, is responsible for this
bias. Which means what day was that?
There was a little more of of matter,
but we call matter than
than anti matter or, yes.
There was to be precise to every
billion particles of anti-matter.
We had 1,000,000,001 ah,
articles of matter. Oh my God.
Really? Yes. Oh, that's tiny.
Excess of one in a billion is enough
to create everything that exists.
Now, the little guy,
we would call that an asymmetry
[inaudible]
so everything we see in the
universe, all the stars,
all the suns and the moons and the graft
and the mountains and us all though
we're the left. We're
the extra stuff. Yes,
we are the result of this asymmetry.
Has Anybody dealt with the real question
that's provoked here? It's like,
why was there more of one stuff kind
of stuff. Then the other kind of stuff,
so there you go. That is
one beautiful question,
but we don't have any
on any final answer yet.
You don't know because you see, you
don't know. We do not know. That's right.
Which is okay. Not knowing is
a wonderful thing in science.
Otherwise it could just retire.
Can I tell you my favorite lawyer
joke told to me by a lawyer? Yeah.
I have to like spread this
because it's the best one.
98% of lawyers give the
other 2% of bad name.
Well, that's the go music. The go
music meaning go away. Anything else?
Or here's a different
place to go to our website,
radiolab.org where you can read more
about anything you heard in this era.
You can see those amazing Lincoln picks
and other things we've got there on
symmetry. And of course you
can subscribe to our podcasts,
which we usually get to hear the
show. You know, whenever you like.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.